[Music]
3 people so far,
58 seriously injured,
2 people wearing double-layered membranes, all set in high alert zone,
tell me about inheritance tax, no hearing
The stage of the duty is currently near Shibaura, Minato-ku. The
encounter point is designated near Edobashi, and evacuation and people of the siege network are completed.
[music]
[applause]
Thank you later
Mr. Parker
tan
par
[applause]
[music]
[music] Since
ancient times, this country has been threatening  Taraburukan
Aratama
Paying for it Kannagi shrine maiden who was chosen as a sword for custody
People call them throwing
Hinami, congratulations, thank you 2nd year junior high school student Yanase, congratulations Thank you, you are Minoseki Gakuin representatives.  I'm sorry my friend, Mai-
chan, Kanami-chan,
I'm sorry for my friend,
Mai-chan,
Kanami-chan.
I'm sorry,
good
night, good night
.
by the front mall none Shibata-chan, please stop It's
difficult,
this is me Kuroko That's right,
thank you
[music] I'm
going
[music]
[applause]
Is it too early?
When I realized I couldn't pop it inside, I made it
2 minutes a.
I love Kuru Kanami-chan's appetizing face
.  About 2 more
hours, ahhh, transfer at Shin-Yokohama.
It
's Koji Ayama's uniform, isn't it?
Ayanokoji?  That uniform entrusted to you by the country,
Heijo Gakukan
Oh, oh,
hello Eto, you're good for tomorrow's match,
oh, oh, oh, oh, what's wrong with your eyes?
I wonder if he's the representative of the mansion
, maybe I'll win tomorrow's match
Mai-chan, I'll wash your back I
don't care if you don't
care  It's like an inn and it's a bit
fun I'm telling you what, the real fun is tomorrow's match
Kanami-chan really
likes swordsmanship  I wonder if it's because it's a game in the game
What should I do if I fail to copy So let's practice with 3 chickens
Eh
Jidori
Magoroku Kanemoto
Complementary pre-copy
Looks like it's going
to be okay
If you face me tomorrow, you'll fight me seriously
[music]
par
Thank you for calming
my soul.  And Suzuka and Yume are security guards at
the venue.
Hey, do your best I
'm nervous, I'm
nervous Hey,
this equal movable property is a
caden You won the tournament two times in a row with the friendship last time
If you don't make it to the finals,
it seems that there will be a lot of junior high school students this year.
Even if you ride the next generation, yes Shido, who won the tournament for the second time in a row, finished all the generations But I
'm not
so
arrogant.
Both sides Kogarasumaru It
's a battle between my juniors and your juniors, isn't it?
Minoseki is
blowing Hetoka Nabe
Last time kazumi oh my God
[music]
stance
[music] It's the
day and I'm
starting
!  I guess I can always win with
that.
Deta Position Day
Let's go with my car
Yeah Yeah Yeah [Music] Hiyori Jujo I think I heard that you transferred right after I was assigned to the Imperial Guard last year aname What
I felt yesterday wasn't an illusion
Why is it all Kanami and Hoida doing this?  Cheerful Kanami-chan
I've been home hundreds of times so far
Mai-chan's face wash is not easy to break We
're all in our hands The tricks are quick
Haa
[music] I
'm sure I want to buy a zone and fight. Haa Let's do our
best together
.
[Music] It
's the first time I've seen Goto's Origami Murasaki
Murasaki is also a great hero 20 years ago
.
Saikyo High School The
finals will start soon The players are already
soho I can fly
I'm excited but I can't stop trembling
Please leave it to me Good
owner
Yume
Kubo 9-dan I don't
dare to call it shibata
That's
it
[music]
Shira Ritsuko I don't have glass I'm
still young Trion
I can't see it in music] ahhh
me
[music]
ana
th
veteran
[music] I
just thought I had a long way to go
[music]
[applause]
Thread ana
[music]